Twitter took unprecedented action
recently on to tweets from president
Donald Trump the first was adding a fact
check notification to a tweet about
mail-in voting and the second was to
place a warning in front of a tweet that
insinuated looters would be shot amidst
the protests over the death of George
Floyd that the platform said violated
its policies about glorifying violence
the fact check of the first tweet
sparked ire from the president that was
only increased by the warning label
placed on the second tweet while twitter
has intervened into the president's
posts Facebook hasn't both messages
appeared unaltered on the president's
Facebook page we have a different policy
I think than Twitter on this you know I
just believed strongly that that
Facebook shouldn't be the arbiter of
truth of everything that people say
online Twitter CEO Jack Dorsey has said
the platform will continue to fact-check
information about elections but how did
Facebook and Twitter come to take
different views on moderating the
President on their platforms it's the
latest question in an ongoing debate
about the responsibility tech companies
have in policing speech online you can
think of online content moderation a bit
like book publishing if a book with
objectionable content like hate speech
was written the publisher would be
responsible for editing that stuff out
before it shipped to bookstores if that
stuff somehow made it into the book in
that book somehow made it onto shelves
the bookstore couldn't be held
responsible for what was in the book
since it had no say in its creation
unlike say a newspaper or a traditional
publisher the platform's operate
completely differently with the idea
that they are sort of providing the
place to put this stuff for individuals
to publish themselves in the 1990s many
early online forums like CompuServe
chose to not actively moderate content
on their sites while other sites like
prodigy did a series of court rulings
determined that sites that actively
moderated their content were more like
publishers and therefore could be held
liable for defamatory content and this
was viewed as kind of being a thing was
just going to greatly
sort of
slow down the development of the
internet in general and really sort of
threaten the ability to build a
functional ecosystem to address this
issue Congress included a provision in
the 1996 Communications Decency Act
called section 230 so section 330
allowed them to be focused on being
platforms and not on being publishers
they could intervene when they wanted to
for the good of their platform but they
didn't have any responsibilities beyond
sort of making sure that they weren't
becoming sort of obsessed pool of
illegal behavior but this prioritization
of growth over moderation came with
consequences in 2016
social media disinformation campaigns
during the election put pressure on
Facebook and Twitter to step up their
moderation efforts we were too slow to
spot this and too slow to act propaganda
through BOTS and human coordination
misinformation campaigns and divisive
filter bubbles that's not a healthy
public square there was a sense that
this was getting to be pre lawless and
also that these ecosystems were
extremely vulnerable to manipulation
Facebook and Twitter both rolled out
fact-checking operations to combat
misinformation Facebook's had sort of an
independent fact-checking program
Twitter's done a bit more stuff
internally but the general idea is that
neither of the platforms want to do much
regulation of speech particularly when
it comes to things like censoring the
president United States but both
internally and externally tech companies
have faced mounting pressure to confront
with the president posts on their
platforms none more so than Twitter
Trump has been a very aggressive user
Twitter it's kind of his native medium
and Twitter recently kind of took a step
Twitter's decision to add its fact-check
label to the president's May 26th wheat
was the first time the platform had
fact-check information outside of the
corona virus pandemic two days after the
tweet the President signed an executive
order seeking to limit the broad legal
protections tech companies have under
Section 230 currently social media
giants like Twitter receiving
unprecedented liability shield based on
the theory that there a neutral platform
which they are not section 230 doesn't
have anything to do with political bias
in fact the poll point of 230 was to
allow them to intervene without fear of
legal repercussion
so this isn't kind of something that is
a natural outgrowth of the law the
morning after the executive order was
signed Twitter placed the warning
message on the president's tweet about
looters while Facebook led to post
appear unaltered Mark Zuckerberg said
that while he personally had a visceral
negative reaction to the post it didn't
violate Facebook's policies when Twitter
sort of stepped into this thing Facebook
ducked Facebook has for years tried to
stay out of regulating political speech
in particular political ads they have
sort of resisted calls from what might
have been natural allies to restrict
this stuff twitter has also applied
another warning label in front of a
tweet by congressman Matt Gaetz saying
it also glorified violence twitter does
seem to be making a decision that there
are some limits it wants to put within
us politics and that's something that
has been kind of a third rail for
American technology companies Zuckerberg
said Facebook will review existing
policies on how it handles content
related to civil unrest or violence
where exactly the president's order and
attempts at legal restrictions on the
platforms and on their moderation go is
unclear this certainly seems like it's
going to draw them deeper into politics
and that's something that Mark
Zuckerberg I think has been desperately
trying to avoid